hi everyone welcome to another episode
of The Gadget Lab show I'm Roberto
Baldwin now Nathan only vadis Giles and
Nathan's going to show us the new HTC
droid DNA LTE something lots of letters
yeah yes this is the HTC droid DNA from
risin it runs on their 4g LTE network
comes out november 21st two hundred
bucks on contract and you know there's a
lot to like here there's a couple things
that I don't like so much but the first
thing really 5-inch display 1080p
resolution that's as high as your HDTV
it's ridiculously high resolution for a
phone it's probably the highest of any
handset you can buy right now so it's
the highest in the Unites States but
doesn't matter i mean if i put that next
to the iphone 5 or any other like really
nice smartphone flagship is it no it
doesn't matter it really doesn't it
really doesn't because the iphone looks
good this looks good the HTC One X the
nexus 4 you know basically almost any
top to your hands that you're going to
go out there and get right nowadays is
going to look good you could say it's
retina display quality this actually has
440 pixels per inch which is higher than
the 326 on the iphone 5 but it doesn't
matter they all look good they all look
great they're beautiful you can watch
videos you play games I've been looking
at magazines they look great but I mean
it's also a 5-inch display I don't
really think I need to live with a
5-inch display it's it's kind of
difficult to use with one hand it's a
bit of a pain and you're a big guy so
big be biggish hands exactly exactly a
smallish person it's just knowledge
hands it's just really five I really do
we need 5 inch display but but if your
behave for the big screen thing this
might be something one check out cool
cool so now I do notice there's one
thing that's kind of lame and that's
this thing on the bottom yeah I I would
say that I kind of really strongly
dislike i'm not sure if hates the right
word but i might even hate it it's just
this little door that covers the USB
port and it just feels like it's going
to break off so when you've bought it
begging to break off so when you buy
this you should just open the box take
the phone out rip the little plastic
thing off just throw in the trash and go
on your merry way maybe maybe that
covers a little USB port here so you can
charge it up I mean you know in other
HTC phones a lot of other
smartphones in general that ports
exposed it's fine I mean I don't know
what they're trying to prevent like
maybe Pocket lint or something peanut
butter it's unnecessary I mean once it's
closed it looks pretty smooth and stuff
but it's just it's going to break off
it's a pain I don't like it I don't like
it don't like it but you know stuff
looks great cool beats audio cares so
next we're gonna have mat Honan on with
the new jawbone up so we're here with
mat Honan indians here with the brand
new job bone up tell us a little bit
about that thing this is a fitness and
activity tracking bracelet from jawbone
it's called the up it's a little band
that has a plug on one side that you can
jack into a smartphone and sync with
well an iphone and sync with it and it
will track your movement and how much
your sleep and you can go into the app
on the smartphone and put our stuff like
about your meals and how you're feeling
excited we r you know sad can you tell
your Sat you can tell it you're sad yeah
and then it tracks what you're doing
through the day the app also has things
like a barcode scanner so that you could
scan in a meal automatically and it's
basically meant to help you be more
aware of the choices you're making and
it even gives you a little to feedback
on how to you know on how to improve
your fitness or your activity level at
least it's like an arm guidance
counselor sort of it's like you're not
doing a very good job right you really
need to make you need to make changes if
you want to light imagine imagine if
your guidance counselor vibrated because
that's how it works it it when like if
you've been sitting around you can set
time limits on it if you've been sitting
around for say 15 minutes 30 minutes 45
minutes it'll vibrate and you know that
you should sort of reminder you should
get up and walk around and do something
and also you know does things like it
tracks your sleep so you can see you
know the next day like oh ok well I'm
not getting good sleep at this time of
the night oh and it even has like a
smart alarm or it figures out that
you're kind of restless in the morning
and it'll wake you up the optimum time
before your alarms
school cool show some guidance counselor
did this whole time yeah yeah awesome so
now this is the second version of this
it's the second version there was a
Joplin up that came out around this time
last year and like a lot of other people
I liked it a lot it was great it was
like one of the best products I used
last year and to quit working all the
sudden and that happened to a lot of
people who had it and the company the
company did a really great thing they
they they not only offered your money
back they said you know what you don't
even have to ship the device back to us
anybody who bought this will get for
your money back and that was very nice
and so they now it's a year later and
they have fixed some things about it it
wasn't they improved the waterproofing
on it basically is the big thing they
did and they made it a little bit more
pliable because the bracelets doing this
all the time one of the things they
found is that the circuit board and the
wine them or handling that as well so
it's more waterproof so it should stand
up better to showers and soap and that
type of thing and it's also a little bit
more bhindi which is a technical term
bendy yeah so cool yeah jawbone up more
bendy and like your guidance counselor
but a little bit more irritating in
vibrating and vibrating a vibrating
irritating guidance counselor so what
don't you like about the the job oh no I
mean there are a few things that I would
prefer to differently like you know
having to plug it into the phone every
time you want to sync it that gets old i
mean i understand that you know by not
having bluetooth that it has a better
battery life you don't have to charge as
often but you know that's kind of a
chore and also it is more bhindi but it
tends to get snagged on things I've
noticed already a lot like I'll be I'll
be taking off
bag or putting something in the car
it'll hook on something and kind of do
this and you know so it might be nice if
it had some sort of actual class that is
that it kept it from kept that from
happening I'm just like flinging off and
you lose it and then you're sad exactly
and then how you're going to tell it
yourself you can tell it thankfully you
can still tell the smartphone app that
you're sad even if your bracelet is gone
okay yeah we should have a full review
on it to here shortly and you'll see all
the things I like and don't like about
it cool well that's it for today's
Gadget Lab show we won't be back next
week because next week is Thanksgiving
and you'll be eating poultry and pork
and whatever else people shove in front
of you but we will be back the week
after that so cool bye bye bye